2020 was an outstanding year for both
tesla
and spacex as both of these companies
achieved tremendous tasks
from promoting the transition to evs
sending people to the iss
from a bigger picture view though it's
no doubt that spacex is much more
important to humanity
long term as they are literally helping
us expand outside of earth
at this point in time though tesla does
have the better financials
and the larger market so they are valued
quite a bit higher than spacex
given spacex's long-term outlook though
when will they overtake tesla
in terms of market cap
well starting off let's address the
elephant in the room
which is tesla's market cap today just a
few weeks ago
tesla boasted a market cap of over 800
billion dollars
this has since cooled down to about 648
billion
but personally i still think that's way
too high for what the business is
today i agree that in 10 or 15 years
tesla will crush these numbers
however there's still a long way to go
and i do think investors are pricing too
much in
today with that being said for our
calculations
we're going to assume that tesla's
valuation cools down by 2030
and that's more reflective of their
fundamental business
for instance instead of a p e ratio of 1
we're going to assume that the p e ratio
comes down to about 50 to 100
which is in line with other growth
companies like amazon by the way
for anyone who doesn't know p e ratio is
a ratio between how much a company earns
and how much they are worth moving on to
spacex they currently aren't a public
company
so they aren't really exposed to the
same market movements that tesla is
currently elon musk refuses to take
spacex public
as he fears that this could hinder their
progress in getting to mars
once they get to mars and establish
consistent back and forth travel though
elon musk is willing to take spacex
public as this is really the only way
insiders of such a massive company who
have been holding for decades
can finally liquidate at least a little
bit of their stake
in the meantime we might see an ipo of
the startling portion of their business
so that's evaluation outlook for both of
these companies
in the long term as in by 2040 to 2050
both of these companies will likely be
public companies with mostly grounded
valuations
with that out of the way let's take a
look at where each of these companies
will stand
in 2030 starting with tesla we're simply
going to be taking a look at the biggest
profit maker for tesla
as delving into each of the sub
businesses would make this video 40 or
50 minutes long
moreover i suspect that 70 to 80 of
their profit
if not more will come from robo taxis
and autonomous software sales
anyways so we should be able to get a
pretty good estimate of their profit
potential
by calculating their annual profit from
robo taxis and then adding about 20
to it to account for their other
businesses tesla is looking to exit the
consumer car market
and fully focus on the robo taxi market
once they have level 5 autonomy working
smoothly
and regulatory approval on their side
many tesla enthusiasts think that tesla
will be able to achieve level 5 autonomy
within the next couple of years
if not this year and the robo taxis are
just around the corner
meanwhile skeptics suggest that robo
taxis aren't coming out until 2040
or 2050 or maybe even never so
we'll take a middle of the road approach
and assume that robotics hit the road in
at that point self-driving software
still might not be perfect
but i think it'll be more than enough to
get government approval and start
getting at least a beta group
on the road this means that at 2030
though tesla will start deploying robot
taxis the majority of the revenue will
still come from regular car sales
so let's take a look at how many cars
tesla will be producing
right now tesla has two main car
factories which are fremont
and giga shanghai they also have two
factories on the way which are giga
berlin and giga texas
each of these factories are able to
produce 500 000 cars per year
or more but we'll call it 500 000 just
to be conservative
if tesla continues at two factories
every single year moving forward tesla
would have 20 factories by 2030
producing about 10 million cars per year
tesla's average selling price today
is still well over 50 000 because of the
luxury models
however as tesla continues to grow and
lower prices and add cheaper models and
all of that
we'll probably see their after selling
price dipped in a low 30 000
range calling it 30 000 tesla would be
pulling in about 300 billion
revenue from car sales annually if we
add about 20
to that in order to account for tesla
solar tesla insurance tesla semi trucks
tesla fsd and all of that
we get a total annual revenue of about
350 billion
as for how much of this is profit
volkswagen usually has a net profit
margin of about five percent
and toyota has a margin of about seven
percent since tesla does benefit from
higher margin software sales as well
we'll use the higher of the two and call
it a seven percent net margin
this would mean that tesla's annual net
profit would be about 25 billion dollars
at today's pe ratio of 1000 tesla would
actually be worth a massive
25 trillion dollars but as we discussed
at the beginning
we'll assume that the p e ratio cools
down to about a hundred like amazon
meaning that tesla would be valued at
about 2.5 trillion
meanwhile spacex's most significant
profit maker in 2030
would likely be starling elon musk is
still hoping to get to mars using
starship within this decade
at this point though i think the early
2030s would be more realistic
but even if spacex is able to achieve
this outstanding goal by 2030
it wouldn't do much to their bottom line
anyways
so we just have to concentrate on
starlink for this decade
as of august 2020 6 was planning to
support about 5 million starling
customers over the next couple of years
with the amount of starlink launches
spacex is successfully completing
and considering that 700 000 people are
already trying to get the service
spacex should easily be able to reach 5
million customers by 2025
especially with the help of starship so
we'll say that they're able to double
that to 10 million customers by 2030
which is a pretty conservative amount
and 80 a month per customer
that totals to 9.6 billion dollars per
year
viasat who is another satellite internet
provider has on that margin of basically
zero
however that's misleading as they are
simply reinvesting everything they make
if we take a look at their operating
margin it's about one to two percent
and that's more indicative of how
profitable the business really is
spacex on the other hand doesn't have to
rely on other companies to launch their
satellites
and they're consistently working on
lowering launch cost
so we'll say they're able to achieve
operating margin of about 5
leaving them with about 500 million
operating profit annually
spacex's other major source of revenue
would of course be commercial launches
and as spacex continues to refine falcon
9 and develop starship
i have no doubt that they'll be able to
grow their annual payload launch
capability
multiple-fold however even now
this is not the most significant
bottleneck rather
there's simply not many commercial
customers looking to launch payloads
i mean the main customers are really
just nasa and the us military
and there's only so many iss supply runs
crew dragon missions
and satellite launches that they'll need
every year in 2019
spacex pulled in an estimated 2 billion
revenue mostly from commercial launch
contracts
in 10 years spacex will likely easily be
able to support commercial contracts
totaling over 20 billion dollars
but i'm not quite sure if there will be
enough commercial interest especially
with the growing competition
so we'll play conservative and call
their commercial revenue 10 billion
dollars in 2030.
elon musk has previously revealed that
relaunching a falcon 9 rocket costs
15 million dollars considering that they
charge their customers 50 million
dollars for launches using reuse
boosters
they have a gross margin of 70 that
doesn't account for operating expenses
though
if half of that goes operating expenses
space x would net about 35
assuming this goes down to about 20
percent and spacex lowers the price they
charge commercial customers
and competition grows spacex would
profit about 2 billion
out of the 10 billion to pull in from
commercial contracts adding this to the
profit from starter link we get a total
potential profit of 2.5 billion dollars
in reality spacex will likely turn
around and invest all of this back into
research and development
so they won't really net anything
however
this is approximately how much they
would make if they focused on
profitability
if we gave them a 100p ratio they would
be worth about 250 billion dollars at
this point
but here's the thing spacex has already
valued at 74 billion dollars today
and considering the massive potential of
space travel i don't see the valuation
multiple cooling down
anytime soon we may very well see a 1000
p e ratio with spacex
which is ludicrous but they do currently
have an
infinite pe ratio so it's definitely
well within the cards
if we give it something a little bit
more grounded like a 200 or 300 pe ratio
we're looking at about a 500 to 750
billion valuation
i wouldn't be surprised if it's over 1
trillion though especially if they reach
mars
as you can see in terms of valuation
spacex would still be quite a bit behind
tesla evaluation
in 2030. if we look further into the
future
this gap actually only gets bigger for
example
let's take a look at tesla in 2040. if
they start to play robo taxis in 2030
they would be able to deploy millions of
robot taxis by 2040.
we already determined that tesla's
production capability would be about 10
million cars per year by 2030.
even if they just dedicated 10 of their
production capability to produce robot
taxis
tesla would be able to pump out 1
million robot taxis every single year
allowing them to grow their fleet to 10
million by 2040.
tesla thinks that each robo taxi will be
able to produce 30 thousand dollars in
profit
every single year with a 10 million
robot taxis
that would give tesla 300 billion profit
every single year
at a p e ratio of 30 to 40 which is what
apple boasts today
tesla would be worth 10 trillion dollars
solely based on the robo taxi business
evidently spacex would be nowhere close
to that by 2040.
no matter how many starling satellites
they launch something else to keep in
mind
is that it's unlikely that tesla doesn't
ramp up robo taxis for a full decade
they do plan to fully transition to just
robo taxis
so i suspect they'll have a much more
aggressive transition plan
maybe they'll transition 10 more of
their production to robo taxis every
single year
for instance 10 percent in 2031 20
2032 30 in 2033 and so on and so forth
at that rate tesla would actually have
55 million robo taxis by 2040
pulling in 1.65 trillion in profit
annually
even at a pe ratio of 20 tesla will be
worth over 30 trillion dollars
looking even further into the future at
2050 tesla could easily have more than
100 million robo taxis
but let's say they call it a day at 100
million robot taxis
and they simply turn to replacing about
10 of their fleet every single year
at this point maybe there's more
competition as well
so maybe their profit per car goes down
to twenty thousand dollars per
year even with that though tesla will be
pulling in two
trillion dollars annually pair that with
a super grounded pe ratio of 10 to 15
and tesla would still be worth 20 to 30
trillion dollars
as you can see spacex simply won't
appeal to as large of a market
anytime soon so when will spacex
overtake tesla
well likely not within this century that
doesn't mean that spacex won't be a
monster company that's worth
trillions of dollars itself it might
even reach a valuation of 10 trillion by
the end of this century
but a valuation in the tens of trillions
like tesla is likely not within the
cards until
after 2100. those spacex may not be the
most valuable company in the world
within our
lifetime i think we can all agree that
it will likely be the most influential
company
of our lifetime do you guys agree
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are fans of
both tesla and spacex
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you